c'est quand même pas normal que ma fille
de 17 ans depuis fleurine de peu plus
d'un an elle arrêtait ses études elle
travaille à la maison ses études par
correspondance qu'on a bien sûr obligé
de payer tous les mois parce qu'elle ne
veut pas me laisser parce que j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un tous les jours et et
je me dis non seulement moi ça m'invite
ça m'a mis ma vie en l'air mais bon moi
je suis maman mais je conçois pas que
mes enfants soient obligés de supporter
tout ça
ce soir Muriel gerton bonsoir
victime du chirurgien de Johnny Hallyday
voilà alors Muriel garcon bonsoir nous
parlerons à 20h de ce qui vous est
arrivé suite à votre opération par le
docteur de la joue mais tout de suite
une question ça fait quoi d'avoir un
point commun avec Johnny Hallyday
j'ai un bien chanter comme lui mais
c'est pas le cas
[Musique]
Muriel robonçoir vous avez 38 ans vous
êtes marié deux enfants 17 et 19 ans
vous habitez Sermaise un petit village
de 1500 habitants dans le Loiret avant
d'être opéré par le docteur delajoue
vous étiez assistante maternelle et vous
aimiez danser
en 1998 vous ressentez de fortes
douleurs dans les lombaires vous
cherchez un neurochirurgien vous
rencontrez le docteur Delajoux qui vous
fait une excellente impression vous le
trouvez sympa gentil rassurant vous avez
envie de lui faire confiance comme on
fait confiance à un membre de sa famille
des donne son numéro de portable en vous
disant appelez-moi quand vous voulez il
m'a mis en confiance surtout que quand
on s'opérer de la colonne vertébrale on
a peur on se demande déjà tout
intervention c'est pas évident d'y aller
mais
il m'a vraiment rassuré il a vraiment
pris les choses en main tout de suite
quoi il s'occupe de tout ils vont
prendre rendez-vous pour le scanner et
prend rendez-vous à la clinique Turin
pour l'opération voilà donc tout va bien
première opération donc en 1998 on vous
met une plaque et des vis dans les
lombaires pas de problème les douleurs
disparaissent donc jusque là tout va
bien mais en 2004 les douleurs
reviennent
les anti-inflammatoires vous sont
d'aucun secours heureusement le bon
docteur de la joue vous rassure il vous
dit que c'est pas grave on va faire une
opération assez simple on va vous mettre
une prothèse entre les vertèbres L4 et
L5 il me dit écoutez c'est bénin comme
opération c'est qu'il voit une
appendicite quoi
c'est moins important que la première
intervention vous avez une hernie il
faut pas vous inquiéter mais quand même
je vais vous mettre une prothèse aux
intérêts épineuses ça s'appelle comme ça
vous inquiétez pas ça ça a bien se
dérouler je précise bien il vous propose
une prothèse entre L4 et L5 voilà le
seul problème c'est les honoraires ça
passe quand même de 12000 francs à 9600
euros
et le réveil est atroce vous avez des
douleurs terribles dans le dos dans les
jambes et là lui il est rassurant il
vous dit c'est normal prenez un peu de
morphine ça va passer oui il me dit
qu'il faut pas que je m'inquiète que on
va continuer à faire des piqûres de et
on va mais en plus me rajouter aux
anti-inflammatoires parce que je lui
précise que mon inquiétude et je lui dis
que j'ai vraiment très mal aux jambes
que je suis vraiment très inquiète il me
dit c'est normal mon dos est fragilisé
donc faut être patiente voilà vous dites
mais j'aimerais bien faire une radio de
contrôle quand même il veut pas il est
pas d'accord il me dit c'est bon vous
pouvez reprendre votre travail je lui
dis ben écoutez j'ai on fait pas la
Redoute contrôle comme la première
intervention il me dit non non c'est pas
la peine ça sert à rien vous pouvez
reprendre le travail comme ça alors
évidemment vous reprenez votre travail
mais c'est une véritable torture pour
vous parce qu'il faut porter des enfants
et tout ça finit par devenir un calvaire
donc au bout de 6 mois de travail je le
rappelle et à ce moment-là il refuse
catégoriquement l'IRM je me dis bon
c'est quand même le médecin
j'essaye de prendre sur moi j'en fais
même pas par ma famille j'ai je me cache
des fois pour craquer parce que ça
devient intolérable même la nuit et puis
au bout de trois fois de trois coups de
fil là je craque la troisième pourquoi
je craque complètement je pleure au
téléphone et je lui dis c'est plus
possible je vois bien qu'il se passe
quelque chose j'en peux plus je suis au
bout du rouleau et là me rassure encore
en me disant écoutez mais non prenez sur
vous c'est un mauvais passage faut pas
c'est outre alors finalement vous allez
voir votre médecin traitant qui vous
prescrit un scanner et là on découvre
que le matériel qui vous a été implanté
n'est pas au bon moment la prothèse qui
devait être entre L5 et L4 et entre L4
et L3 oui tout à fait voilà alors en
fait faudrait réopérer pour retirer le
matériel le mettre au bon endroit mais
évidemment votre dos c'est dégradé à
travers toutes ces opérations etc et
dans l'immédiat pour traiter la douleur
on vous donne de la morphine la
cortisone et surtout un corset en résine
que vous êtes obligé de porter 24 heures
sur 24 Muriel oui parce que à ce moment
là je pouvais même plus me tourner dans
mon lit c'était à hurler je restais sur
le dos et j'étais obligé de réveiller
mon mari la nuit même en magrippant à
mon drap je pouvais pas c'était mon mari
qui me basculait de temps en temps sur
les côtés pour pouvoir me soulager alors
il y a un réveillon vous tombez dans les
pommes c'est carrément c'est c'est
terrible la douleur alors finalement
vous êtes opéré le succès de l'opération
est assez relative vous retrouvez
l'usage de votre jambe droite mais les
douleurs continuent dans la jambe gauche
et puis votre dos c'est toujours un
calvaire et là vous commencez à vous
déplacer en fauteuil roulant vous êtes
obligé d'avoir quelqu'un pour vous aider
à vous laver vous pouvez plus bosser
quoi vous avez perdu votre boulot vous
êtes en pleine dépression vous prenez
des médicaments pour lutter contre la
dépression votre mari aussi vous avez
des problèmes financiers colossaux
évidemment puisque vous travaillez plus
le sexe n'en parlons pas parce
qu'évidemment votre mari vous voit
souffrir comme ça c'est pas très puis
vous avez pas trop envie non plus quand
vous souffrez 24 heures sur 24
c'est une catastrophe cette histoire
alors le 15 novembre dernier l'expert
médical du tribunal dit d'abord il n'y a
pas eu ce qu'on appelle le consentement
éclairé c'est-à-dire que vous avez
jamais signé une lettre disant que vous
admettez les conséquences possibles de
ce type d'opération les risques encourus
et surtout il y a ce problème de
prothèse qui a pas été placé au bon
endroit ça ça a été quand même reconnu
par un expert dans l'univers c'est pas
voilà alors quand vous avez appris que
Johnny Hallyday avait eu les mêmes
problèmes avec le même docteur quel a
été votre réaction Muriel
je me suis dit je me suis battue toute
seule j'ai essayé de faire bouger les
choses mais quand vous êtes petit les
choses se bougent pas et là je me suis
dit mais ouf enfin quelqu'un qui est
connu avec voilà on va pouvoir nous
écouter mais finances sont comment sont
catastrophiques donc avocat pas possible
obligé de passer par son service
juridique que j'avais de ma banque donc
on ne choisit pas forcément l'avocat
qu'on veut enfin je veux dire c'est le
pot de terre contre le pot de fer alors
Johnny Hallyday a porté plainte cette
semaine on n'est pas là pour faire le
procès du docteur de la joue évidemment
la question c'est de savoir que vous
vous choisissiez de l'ajout c'est une
chose mais que les stars continuent à
aller chez lui je comprends pas moi les
stars on les comprend pas toujours
Thierry l'argent il y a des sociabilités
liées à l'argent il y a un monde où on
ne compte pas c'est terrible c'est des
il y a des faits divers qui illustrent
profondément les inégalités dans notre
société
on va voir ce que pense Blacko de ce qui
est arrivé à Johnny
la planète
peu le principal c'est que notre Johnny
national soit toujours vivant
[Musique]
monsieur johnny c'est la France l'idole
que c'est choisi tout un peuple
des fois on se dit Éric Besson a raison
de se faire du souci pour l'identité
nationale que le peuple français se
reconnaissent dans un Belge qui se prend
pour un Américain et qui vit en Suisse
ça en dit long sur la haute opinion que
les Français ont de même mais que
voulez-vous jean-Philippe Smet est né en
43 en plein Paris occupé alors forcément
il aurait préféré être américain de
Gaulle est parti à Londres
c'est ça la France en tout cas quel
soulagement de voir notre vieux cowboy
toujours en selle même Nicolas Sarkozy
s'est dit rassuré je voudrais dire
Johnny Hallyday les vœux que l'on forme
pour que sa santé s'améliore bah tu
m'étonnes qu'il est rassuré si notre
mascotte nationale était morte à force
de travailler plus pour gagner plus et
oublier de
vivre ça la foutait mal avant les
régionales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de Julien gras bravo donc Johnny quand
il est sorti du commun ces paroles
étaient incompréhensibles et tout le
monde a dit bah c'est normal il va bien
ça y est
on a quand même dit et entendu beaucoup
beaucoup de bêtises là pendant huit
jours par exemple des tas de gens qui
disaient je l'ai vu je lui ai parlé il
va bien il se bat il était dans le coma
artificiel donc je sais pas comment ils
savent qu'il va bien et qui se battent
son état normal bon
ouais
voilà mais après Johnny les spéculations
sur la tournée de trop etc tout ça c'est
du bullshit d'ailleurs johnny c'est un
mec de scène chanter c'est ce qui fait
c'est ce qu'il aime c'est un défi
permanent s'il peut rechanter on le
souhaite et vraisemblablement il le fera
il le fera dès que possible parce que
c'est ça qui fait c'est ça qui l'est
mais c'est une bête de scène c'est aussi
une bête de somme c'est à ce que vous
pensez pas que pour qu'il fasse cette
tournée avec les problèmes qu'il avait
on l'a un peu shooté à la cortisone
quand même oui bien sûr il a pris des
anti-inflammatoires des antibiotiques
etc c'est évident mais il les
vraisemblablement demander c'est pas on
achève bien les chevaux je veux dire il
n'y a personne qui oblige Johnny à
monter sur scène ou à faire des dates
etc c'est lui il le veut c'est ce qu'il
est pas manipulé par son entourage pour
faire de l'argent comme Michael Jackson
mais non mais Thierry alors un truc
c'est que quelqu'un essaie de manipuler
Johnny Hallyday je lui souhaite du
courage mais oui évidemment il est
indépendant il est comme les gens dont
je parle dans dans mon livre c'est sa
nature c'est des trompes la mort c'est
des forces de la nature puis c'est des
gens qui sont mus à la fois par la
passion et aussi par un vide
d'existentiel qui fait qu'ils ont besoin
du contact avec leur public d'aller
faire le truc qui font et de vérifier de
valider l'amour que leur porte le regard
des autres vous verrez dès qu'il va être
un peu sur pied le premier truc qu'il va
faire c'est remonter sur scène et puis
il va vouloir en mettre plein la gueule
à tout le monde pour montrer qu'il va
bien et qu'il est toujours le patron
quand vous voyez que tout le monde est
sur Johnny comme ça tout se barreau ça
vous fait quoi Muriel bah ça fait mal
parce que on se dit moi ça fait deux ans
plus deux ans que je suis dans cette
galère
ça a vraiment détruit ma vie aujourd'hui
c'est un fauteuil manuel mais la plupart
du temps c'est le fauteuil électrique je
vis dans ma chambre les trois quarts de
mon temps dans les médicalisé les portes
sont pas adaptées ma salle de bain est
au premier étage donc tout ça ça coûte
et j'ai pas les moyens j'ai pas les
moyens qu'on me donnait moyen d'aménager
ma maison
c'est quand même pas normal que ma fille
de 17 ans depuis fleurine de peu plus
d'un an elle arrêtait ses études elle
travaille à la maison ses études par
correspondance qu'on a bien sûr obligé
de payer tous les mois parce qu'elle ne
veut pas me laisser parce que j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un tous les jours et et
je me dis non seulement moi ça m'invite
ça m'a mis ma vie en l'air mais bon moi
je suis maman mais je conçois pas que
mes enfants soient obligés de supporter
tout ça parce qu'elle a sa jeunesse à
faire comme mon mon fils me dit maman
mais on voit bien tu nous souris le soir
mais on sait bien que tu es pas bien ça
nous fait mal quand on rentre le soir
donc c'est pas normal je me dis tout ça
et ces aides là bah c'est vrai que faut
reconnaître que quand on a pas d'argent
on n'a pas ses aides là c'est impossible
quand on vous demande de aménager une
maison juste une douche on vous demande
10000 €, bah les 10000 €, je les ai pas
et c'est une simple douche on ne demande
pas un truc énorme on demande juste
qu'on nous casse une porte pour mettre
une douche mais c'est moyen on les a pas
donc si on les a pas on peut pas nous
aider vous savez quoi vous devriez
essayer de contacter Johnny et je suis
sûr que c'est un homme qui a
beaucoup de cœur et qui a un lien
maintenant avec vous un lien malheureux
et je suis sûr que voilà ça vaut le coup
de lui demander si lui il ferait pas
quelque chose pour vous aider
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu